- As many people have observed,
of the thousands of people that streamed
into the Capitol on Wednesdays riots,
very few have been arrested.
On the order of 50 or 60 people despite
the fact that five people
have now lost their lives
including one Capitol police person.
And on top of that,
it's a national security nightmare.
The computers of the members
of Congress were accessed,
files may have been stolen.
And there's no good reason as
to why these people weren't arrested
and detained instead of just
letting them out scott free.
Well, the good news is there's
no reason that stops the FBI
or the department of justice
from arresting these people
after the fact.
It's an evidentiary issue.
It's not a legal impediment.
It's not like if you flee a crime scene,
you're suddenly absolved of the crime.
It's just a,
an evidentiary matter of going through all
of the social media posts.
And luckily these people were not afraid
to videotape themselves
and just finding the guilty parties.
It can happen after the fact,
days, weeks, months or even years later.
But anyway,
I'll see you in court.
And if you were there on Wednesday,
maybe literally.